Yes, we will try to speak Ukrainian
now we are
speaking Ukrainian Sergey Good
evening Good evening we have frankfurters
good morning everything is
interesting in Ukraine it is now
21:00 walk 15 minutes we have evening It is
evening
you have 21:00 we
will
talk
talk talk in Ukrainian Although
not  Ukrainian is more correct, but
Ukrainian is interesting. This is the most
common mistake they say in
Russian, it came from Russian. In Ukrainian, you have to
speak Ukrainian, not Ukrainian,
even speak Ukrainian.
communicate
like this
through
YouTube
you
said they said
it would be interesting
to hear how you work I
speak Ukrainian and then
we made contact via Skype and now we are
talking now it is a
miracle it is fantastic
what cool words Yes it is really
fantastic that you can be somewhere
in Canada A  I'm here in Ukraine, we can
communicate easily. It's really cool. It's
cool, but I
can say that
2-3 months ago, I
knew very, very little about Ukraine,
but now for two months, every day I
listen to
that caste about the situation and Ukraine. He
listens to the Ukrainian language, and
I can  to say that
because you have
a lot of problems
with Eastern Ukraine, but I have the
impression that Ukraine has already become
more
Elina,
you
can
persuade
were more loyal to Russia,
but on the other hand, it separated us from
Russia in some way, that is, people who left
were loyal to Russia, now they do not
treat it so well, and in this
regard, it may be bad, but on the other
hand, in fact, it is  united, but
on the one hand, it unites us and divides us
more with the people who are in the east, but of course, it is
also the same, on the other hand,
it is
important to unite
people who are
residents of eastern Ukraine, and  uh, that's
why
I
think that you have a door in Ukraine.
If you had a door of
state languages,
the situation would help.
In fact, Russia plays a big role, so
we hope that she, or as they say, the
decentralization of power, what he will be able to
change, we'll see, we'll see, but it's generally
interesting that there are people on  in the east, who
speak Russian but at the same time
support Ukraine. I don’t know. It’s quite
pleasant to feel when a person defends
Ukraine and at the same time speaks Russian.
Many people are fighting for the unity of
Ukraine.
There are
Russian-speaking people.
in my opinion,
he speaks
Russian
like a patriot,
and he
speaks better, like Ukrainian,
because Ukraine has a center of Russian,
Russian culture is cool, and Russian culture gives a
great, great culture, and I don’t see
why you do
n’t recognize Russian as the
state language, but I’m not Ukrainian, I
Canada, we have a door, the
state languages ​​are not a problem for me, I
already know that Ukraine has a lot of history, a lot of
situations, a lot of it, it’s complicated, it’s complicated, the situation is complicated,
how many
Russian people and Ukrainian people,
apparently, especially after these events, that is,
if, for example, I were offered to introduce
English to a friend  the state one, then I would
agree, I
agreed to the English friend without problems, the state one,
but for example Russian, I do
n’t really have the desire. I don’t know why, but I
don’t have the desire, although I understand that
it was honest, but as a Ukrainian,
as a patriot, I don’t have the desire. I don’t know. How is
it?  It is happening, but there is no desire, but
we in Canada are a
country
because English is
7-10%.  and French is 25 and the majority of
people will be against
French as the state language, but
this is an important
protection to sit down with
less rights But you have in Ukraine
who is not a mouse
after all, probably somehow our culture
affects and All this affects, in fact, I
say it would be honest  to do Russian but but I
don't know something I I don't even know it
somehow already Maybe
subconsciously I don't even know but yes Yes it
is but
you
don't speak English very well
I guess I don't really know
if I speak it's probably with my
friends who are also studying
I don't know much English. I communicate somewhere on the Internet.
Thank you for the discussion. It's
very interesting and
I hope that
we will have
opportunities.
A5 A5 again.